[Music]
celebrities are about to move into this
house we think we know famous people
because of the roles that they play on
the big screen or the small screen what
I'm looking forward to is seeing what
happens you know behind the magic behind
the hair makeup behind the curtain I'm
surprised that celebrities are even
doing this
listen celebs y'all are gonna crack okay
I don't know I don't care what you say I
don't care how hyped up you are get
ready put your big-boy panties on girls
if you think that you're gonna keep your
sanity you're wrong you're gonna lose it
hundreds don't lose it
I just want to see the human side of you
know celebrities don't be emotional
don't get in a showmance understand that
you're recorded all the time and don't
get in a showmance this is unscripted
and uncensored and you're gonna be feed
all over in your life you better be
mentally prepared and you better be able
to play it there's nothing that they can
do to prepare them for what is about to
happen
whichever ones the biggest celebrity
make sure that like whoever Span Garlin
over you just keep them around you think
you know how to play the game but the
second you step foot in that house it's
all crap you don't know what you're
doing you don't know who to trust don't
believe anybody don't believe anybody
don't trust anybody don't go with the
crowd if you think you're moving into a
mansion you're dead wrong I just kind of
accept it for what it is there's one
bathroom good luck with that
pretend you're back in college and
pretend you're in the college gone and
use it that way pack more lounging
clothes than you think you need because
you're living in a house you need way
less heels than you than you think you
need watch and observe
I definitely exercise your social and
like make sure your social game is on
point
just be yourself I mean hell yeah you
can tell when somebody's not being
themselves in there it's just a fun
experience as long as you know people
don't heat you
[Music]